hello there Marvel Spider-Man lets us
switch between Peter and Miles freely
and just like the GTA 5 days there's a
chance something epic will happen in
transition each clip is only around 3
seconds long today we're going through
all 30 animations when switching between
the two webs Slingers from bird attacks
to spider stare offs let's do this let's
get the boring ones out of the way first
the majority of the time the Spider-Man
will simply swing in and either land
drop down or continue swinging by yet
depending on where you are on the map
the switch can activate other things
like this Peter can be drinking his
coffee when blinking you'll miss it a
flock of birds will dump that hot
beverage all over his groin and Miles
doesn't have much of a better time
either because one of those flying rats
straight up takes his tasty beverage
both Spider-Man demonstrate some
impressive Feats of skill miles will
flip into action in epic style while
Peter can be found up high showing his
strength with a single arm handstand how
the Spider-Man use their downtime tells
us a great deal about them miles is
constantly checking his phone on the
Move while Peter will make a spiderweb
hammock to read messages in private he's
been Spider-Man much longer than Miles
and knows the tricks of the trade well I
thought he did until this animation
popped up Pete can also be found almost
falling asleep perched on a high
building everything okay miles and Peter
can also be seen interacting with New
Yorkers miles shares a wave and a joke
while Peter will give directions to
tourists he also has time to take a
selfie with some too and on very rare
occasions he'll stroll straight into a
super fan with many different
reactions miles has an ultra rare
animation of him eating a bagel he'll
even lift the mask to take a bite this
is kind of an Easter egg for the
spiderverse skin Remember the Time Miles
threw a bagel and changes the Multiverse
forever he should have eaten it just
like this version of mm what's up New
York I'm sure you've all seen Peter
doing his situps moments before being
back on duty but have you seen him
juggle man's got skills while Smiles
would prefer to listen to some beats on
his headphones some moments are not as
glamorous as others and some are
downright sad both of the Spider-Man can
be seen visiting their fallen loved ones
at the cemetery the sacrifices made by
Jeff and Aunt May will never be
forgotten the final four animations are
more spider related as both Peter and
miles will spend a moment chasing down a
Wandering spiderbot great for a massage
miles takes this one step further at
Green spaces he can be found up close
and personal staring at a real spider a
freaking huge one in Central Park anyone
from New York here are the spiders there
really that big and finally here's the
most unexpected transition I witnessed
from Peter to Miles check it
out what's up New
York
okay you weren't expecting to see that
today were you I have fall damage on and
it's true Miles Morales will leap from
the top of the Empire State Building and
literally will'll just fall until you
take over and I
didn't I'm Madam it's been a pleasure
subscribe for more Spider-Man secrets
and E stgs coming very soon see you